[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen zum garten
youtuber adventskalender dieses jahr bin
ich auch mit dabei letztes jahr weiß ich
gar nicht ob es den kanal davon gab es
vielleicht gerade so aber da wusste ich
noch nicht von diesem adventskalender
ich habe das gerade zufällig vor kurzem
mitbekommen dass das gibt es eine ganz
tolle aktion
das haben denn vom garten gemüse kios
übrigens ein ganz toller kanal und max
von der garthen kanal zusammen ins leben
gerufen um einfach mal danke zu sagen
für die ganzen lieben kommentare es ist
ja so krass was man alles so zurück
bekommt dafür dass man garten videos im
internet macht also das ist unglaublich
und ich freue mich total dass ich dieses
jahr mit dabei sein kann weil ich das
eine ganz tolle idee findet also auch
noch mal danke an denn und max dass ihr
das ins leben gerufen hat und dass ihr
das auch dieses jahr wieder organisiert
schaut mal unten in die video
beschreibung weil da findet ihr alle
anderen kanäle die mitmachen da sind
ganz tolle kanäle dabei also schaute auf
jeden fall mal rein natürlich in 1 bis 7
sind ja schon erschienen und dann geht
es morgen weiter bei mir das von daten
viel fall den ich übrigens auch total
super sind also schaut euch auf jeden
fall auch die anderen kanäle an die da
mitmachen weil ihr da auch jeden tag
etwas gewinnen könnt ich habe mir
überlegt dass ich saatgut verloren
möchte und noch ein bisschen mehr
also fangen wir mal an das ist alles
saatgut aus unserem garten
ich werde das in drei teilen weil wir
werden drei der kim verschicken die
jeweils identisch sind
und da bekommt zum beispiel eine ganze
ecke risch dann wohnen neckar königin
dann natürlich das darf nicht fehlen und
ich weiß dass ihr zusammen bedingt haben
wollt das ist saatgut von unserem
parcours salat den so viele von euch
nicht bestellen konnten weil das den
fast nirgendwo zu kaufen gibt und der
immer super schnell ausverkauft ist das
ist ein salat den man auch im winter
ernten kann der sehr sehr frost hat und
eine supertolle unglaublich leckere
sorte wir haben das saatgut auch nur
einmal gekauft vor sechs sieben jahren
oder so unser dem vermehren wir das
immer wieder in unserem garten weiter
weil man ist einfach fast nicht bekommt
und dann haben wir hier noch feldsalat
saatgut auch über schön gerade jetzt
wenn es meine lieblingsgemüse im winter
dazu gibt es für jeden der gewinnt den
maria tonight kalender das ist der
ausländer nachdem wir gärtnern auf den
ich richtig schwere und den ich ganz
toll finde ich blende da oben alles wort
werbung ein weil ich jetzt hier produkte
in die kamera halte
und der ist auf jeden fall super super
cool und wir werden die sachen anfang
januar verschicken so dass sie auch noch
rechtzeitig bei euch sind also maria
2021 und dann bekommt jeder der drei
gewinner auch noch einen platz in meinem
gemüsegarten starten onlinekurs das ist
ein video kurs den ich erstellt habe wo
ich das ganze jahr über schritt für
schritt zeigen wie man einen richtig
produktiven pflegeleichten und
wunderschönen gemüse garten anlegt das
sind glaube ich über 50 wenn nicht sogar
60 videos die euch durch das ganze
garten jahr begleiten wo ich wirklich an
die hand nehmen und schritt für schritt
zeige wie wir hier bei uns so gerten
dass wir möglichst wenig arbeit haben
mit der natur arbeiten statt gegen die
natur und dabei auch noch ein
riesengroßer ernte einfahren können also
da freue ich mich total wenn ich drei
von euch mit in den gemüsegarten kurs
2021 aufnehmen kann
der geht im februar los aber ihr bekommt
euren zugang schon vorher so dass sie
auch schon vor den anderen mal einen
blick reinwerfen können und vielleicht
sogar schon gebiete anlegen könnt wenn
ihr vorher schon zeit habt also das sind
die drei pakete die ich verlosen möchte
da ist jeweils einmal das saatgut drin
hier wird einmal der haushalt kalender
und jeder bekommt einen zugang zum tor
ist und um teilzunehmen habe ich mir
gedacht wäre es total schön wenn ihr
einfach mal unten in die kommentare
schreibt wer euer lieblings youtuber ist
in der garten wie scheuer lieblings
garten youtuber jetzt nicht ich sondern
irgendwie anders weil die meisten die
hier zuschauen wahrscheinlich wird sie
wechseln die sie schon kennen
schön und so unterstützenswert wenn
leute in ihrem garten videos machen um
anderen leuten zu helfen ihr eigenes
essen anbauen ich finde es einfach
richtig klasse und deswegen schreibt auf
jeden fall mal euren garten lieblings
co.uk und in die kommentare damit nehmen
sie am gewinnspiel teil und ich werde
dann anfang januar mit einem kommentar
also wie wir das immer machen mit
gewinnspielen zufällig eine person aus
losen dann schreibe ich oder 3gs und
natürlich dann schreibe ich unter den
kommentar darunter dass die person
gewonnen hat und dann müsst ihr
antworten und eure e-mail-adresse unter
diesen kommentar kommentieren damit wir
euch kontaktieren können das ist ganz
wichtig dass ihr das macht weil wir euch
nur so kontaktieren können um eure
adresse abzufragen und auch eine e
mailadresse brauchen um euch den zugang
zum video kurs zu erstellen teilnehmen
könnt ihr bis zum 31.12 auch bei den
anderen kanälen also schaut auf jeden
fall in die video beschreibung morgen
geht es weiter mit dem nils von satten
vielfalt der einen richtig richtig schön
kanal hat also schaut morgen beim jetzt
vorbei und ansonsten ziehen wir uns am
samstag wieder für das nächste video